the way it the way meritocracy economic
meritocracy has played out in the United
States I do have a problem with because
I think it's I think it's a myth or you
know as I call it it I think it's a dead
idea in that sense I think not
necessarily among everyday Americans but
I think among the you know what you
might call the educated class the what I
call the lower upper class in the book I
think there's a sense that's built up
that people end up economically where
they deserve to and that's a function of
the kind of long transition in our
culture to the s80 driven system of
college admissions the way the young
people you know from an early age sort
of jump through those hoops and and if
they're successful doing that and
they're successful gaining access to the
best colleges they sort of feel a kind
of entitlement to the lion's share of
the material rewards that society has to
offer and I think you know put aside the
fact that there's obviously no link
between that kind of merit and any kind
of dignity or moral you no sense of
sense of worth in society but I think
it's also true and I think lower uppers
are increasingly realizing that there
isn't a link between even merit in that
sense and that narrow sense and who ends
up the wealthiest or more most powerful
in society you've got the rise of the
undeserving ultra rich as I call it in
the book you know CEOs who end up
presiding over the demolition of
companies like Charles Prince at
Citigroup or the fellow at countrywide
or all these folks who have walk away
with a hundred million dollars two
hundred million dollars while not only
their companies are decimated and tens
of thousands of people end up laid off
but you know that the subprime mortgage
peddlers are all retired to the country
club now while the entire country is
going through the worst crisis since the
depression so you know the question I
ask is you know how ubiquitous does this
kind of undeserving wealth become before
it becomes so corrosive in a democracy
that it wrongly discredits capitalism
altogether so i think the lower upper is
looking at that are realizing that money
doesn't necessarily follow merit the way
they'd quite assumed and what i think is
that is they look up and see that and
these are this is an important segment
of society these couple million p
people who are senior vice presidents of
marketing their their professors their
media observers they're professionals
lawyers doctors who themselves have
become to chafe a little bit and and see
the sort of unimaginable wealth above
them when they thought they themselves
were positioned to be quite comfortable
and i think that the empathy that may
awaken in them for the far greater group
that's below them on the income scale
will help them become a constituency for
the kind of security and opportunity
agenda we need for the country at a time
of all this rapid economic change
I don't think it's fair to blame one
party or another for this and you know I
suppose it's tempting to say somehow
it's all it's all a function of
parenting because somewhere along the
line there was a kind of ethical compass
and a especially a leadership ethic that
got lost and I think that you know when
I read the headlines every day it's hard
not to think that we're not seeing a
failure of elites in every segment of
society I mean whether it's you know
Bernie Madoff abusing the trust this is
a guy who's chairman of the Nasdaq or
respected member of The Wall Street
Community you know a bastion of the
Jewish community I mean it's it's you
know this kind of stuff is shocking but
you know the whole the whole idea that
you've got CEOs who walk away with
gazillions while their companies
absolutely go into the tank auto auto
shock us and I'm actually surprised that
there's not more political upheaval as a
result of this i think if the economic
times get worse I think they'll be more
of a backlash in the road